how well does Justin Thomas remember his
iconic shot at the PGA Championship what
color shirt were you wearing pink what
was the par on 17. three what club were
you using seven iron what commentator
um I think Dottie was out she was on the
course I don't know who was necessarily
in the booth how many yards was the hole
I want to say it was 217 but I don't
know what the adjustment was with the
downhill what was your score before the
hole I made birdie I think to get to
nine under so I was 800 before that how
many strokes were you leading by I was
leading by one at the time I birdied
while kids made bogey when I was on 17.
how many times did you look up while
practicing your swing before finally
hitting uh two what was your ball speed
on this hole
that's not a fair question I don't know
why I want to say 129 or 135 yeah I
don't know ball speeds very well it just
was a perfect opportunity for me just to
hit a full seminar and try to land at
about six eight Paces on the green
fortunately it rolled do about 10 12
feet and I made it